next a real life love story that shows
timing is everything people reports a
couple named paul mattingly and laura
lee estes got married for the second
time over the pandemic after living
apart for 40 years look at them their
first wedding was in 1980 fresh out of
college they were too young to make it
work
and then they divorced and they drifted
apart but then in 2019 laura lee was
passing through paul's town and reached
out and did he want to go to dinner she
asked they were both single paul says
the moment he saw her it was love at
second sight oh laura lee said it was
like seeing the best friend you haven't
seen in years and they just celebrated
their one year anniversary in their 60s
and now their mantra is they just want
to make up for lost time i love that
this is so cute
that goes in the timing is everything
absolutely and you know i when i call
this i've said it here before i i love
when people hook up again i call it
reheating your leftovers you know when
it's been in the fridge for a while you
liked it once maybe i just nuke it a
little bit i'll want it again 40 years i
hope it was in the freezer yeah not the
fridge in a nice tupperware yeah right a
little like walt disney cryo
totally is there are there any leftovers
in your fridge that you like just can't
stop thinking about maybe one day it's
going to heat them up are we talking
about boys or soups i was not talking
about soup okay um yes i have revisited
a few exes and i keep coming up with the
same
thing which is a lot of good like
self-discovery that i've really grown up
a lot and i've made a lot of concerted
effort to kind of
change my patterns and behaviors so it's
kind of like all good news it is good
news and i you know i do believe timing
is everything right you could meet the
right person at the wrong time yeah
clearly they didn't how beautiful they
reconnected 40 years later i think it's
very helpful
i love it i love it um
yeah none of my exes are interested and
there's nothing there they're all like
bird carcasses oh my god
i'm telling you all the relationships in
my past are like there's nothing left
there's nothing to revisit
they picked all the meat off
it's like vultures flying over and
they're like nothing to eat here
[Music]